bonsoir
liberté égalité fraternité
cette devise résonne comme une musique à
la fois sacré est familière elle exprime
notre attachement à un patrimoine
politique commun celui des droits de
l'homme elle est associée aux lumières
mais elle a des zones d'ombré l'ombre la
plus visible et celles qui résident dans
le décalage entre la proclamation des
principes et leur difficile application
entre l'égalité formelle et les
inégalités effective
comment comprendre la persistance de ces
décalages
comment comprendre ces promesses non
tenues pour cela nous devons pas nous en
tenir aux comment mais nous poser la
question du sens de ces principes dans
leurs relations
la fraternité est elle la condition où
la conséquence de l'application des
principes d'égalité de liberté
faut-il que nous reconnaissions comme
des frères c'est à dire comme semblable
parce qu'appartenant à la même famille
pour que nous soyons en légitimité
d'être des citoyens égaux et libres ou
deux venant nous des frères parce que
nous sommes élevés comme des citoyens
égaux et libres
il ya là une vraie question celle de
savoir qui sont les frères et donc
qu'ils sont les noms frère
si la devise ne s'adressait pas aux
frères mais aux soeurs et était donc
formulé ainsi liberté égalité sororité
je pense que vous seriez nombreux à
penser que la sororité ne représente ni
l'universel ni la neutralité lever le
tabou du péché originel de la république
ce péché originel de la fraternité
c'est voir que les femmes n'ont pas été
les seuls exclus de la république
française si les femmes ont été sortis
du politique de cette communauté de
citoyens libres et égaux en étant
renvoyés à leurs missions et à leur
vocation prétendu monde naturel de mer
ce que l'on qualifie par une couleur
mais qui sont en réalité renvoyer à un
manque les non blancs ont aussi été
assignés à cette incapacité d'être des
aides de raison en prenant de la
distance par rapport à leur vocation
naturelle de sauvages de sauvageons
enchaîné dans leur instinct ou leurs
traditions
comme le disait aimé césaire lennon
frères renvoi si citoyen à parents n'ont
pas à part entière mais entièrement à
part car les hommes blancs ont été en
position d'avoir ce pouvoir exorbitant
est fondamental de faire la
classification de ce qui est politique
et de ce qui est naturel et ils se sont
bien sûr mis tout en haut de la pyramide
où en sommes nous aujourd'hui dans la
société française du début du xxième
siècle ne sommes plus dans une ère de
l'exclusion mais dans celle de
l'inclusion bien sûr que nous pouvons
nous en réjouir
la seconde moitié du 20e siècle a joué
un rôle fondamental vers l'accès à
l'égalité de droit les femmes ne sont
plus des mineurs juridiquement
elles ont le droit de voter d'être
éligible de choisir leur emploi de gérer
leurs biens propres
mais rappelons nous que si l' ordonnance
accordant les le droit de vote et
d'éligibilité a été signé à alger
en 1944 les musulmanes de large de
l'algérie française ont dû attendre 1958
pour voter aujourd'hui donc la bonne
nouvelle c'est que tous les français
sont des français à part entière
juridiquement qu'il y avait deux
critères de
pour lutter contre les discriminations
nous sommes donc dans une législation
égalitaire et pour autant vivons nous
dans une société égalitaire égal nous
sommes tous à dénoncer les inégalités
salariales
en moyenne les hommes gagnent en france
23% de plus que les femmes
avec 11% qui demeurent inexpliquées
disons le mot qui sont la résultante de
discrimination il ya des discriminations
racistes comme le montre en particulier
l'enquète trajectoires et origines les
discriminations religieuses en
particulier al embauche sont très
importantes
un rapport de l'institut montaigne qui a
fait un travail de testing montre que un
même cv avec des signes montrant que le
candidat est musulman aura quatre fois
moins de chances d'avoir un retour qu'un
cv montrant que le candidat est un homme
chrétien catholique
alors comment continuer ce chemin vers
l'égalité
comment dépasser ces inégalités
la réponse en vogue aujourd'hui est de
dire que pour lutter contre les
discriminations pour inclure ces noms
frères historique
il faut à la fois montrer que c'est
juste bien sûr mais aussi avant tout que
c'est rentable
il y a en particulier un rapport qui a
été rendu en septembre dernier par le
conseil d'analysé économique au
gouvernement et qui montre que lutter
contre les discriminations dans l'emploi
permettrait de gagner des centaines de
milliards d'euros ça ressemble à une api
ya là une fin hollywoodienne à la
française où l'éthique le politique et
l'économique irresponsable et man dans
le même sens
alors pourquoi bouder le plaisir
l'efficacité de ce gagnant gagnant
pourquoi est-ce que je viens ici gâcher
la fête
il y a trois raisons la première c'est
que ces travaux montrant que la mixité
et performantes sont scientifiquement
discuter qu'ils sont idéologiquement
signifiant et enfin qui
son pragmatiquement limité très
rapidement toute décision politique a
tendance à montrer sa légitimité en
s'appuyant sur des enquêtes si possible
scientifique des chiffres vous avez bien
entendu parler a entendu parler du fait
que si lehman brothers avait teleman
sisters il n'y aurait pas eu la crise ça
provenait en particulier d'une recherche
faisant le lien entre le taux de
testostérone et la prise de risque et
cette recherche démontre et donc plus
vous aviez testostérone plus vous
preniez de risque ce qui était bien en
période de profits mais ce qui en
période de crise crée des descentes plus
rapides nous les décideurs politiques se
sont en particulier emparé de cette
étude fortement remise en cause dans sa
scientificité pour justifier la mise en
place de quotas dans les conseils
d'administration pour inclure les femmes
dans les instances de décision en disant
bah voilà comme ça il y aura une
complémentarité entre ceux qui prendront
des risques et puis les autres qui
géreront en bonne mère de famille
vous voyez quand même l'un pointé une
idéologie qui est discutée mais qui est
très discutée celle du déterminisme
biologique
les slogans très tentant du type les
femmes font de la politique autrement du
management autrement son réalité avec un
poids très fort qui est celui d'un
sexisme bienveillant bienveillant
puisqu'il inclut au lieu d'exclure mais
il reste sur le même modèle qui est
celui d'inclure les noms frère pour les
mêmes raisons qu'on les a exclus c'est à
dire pour leur singularité pour leurs
différences pour leur complémentarité et
non pas parce qu'ils sont reconnus comme
des frères comme des semblables
de la même manière vous avez tous
entendu que la diversité c'est bon pour
le business
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que là
encore on est dans du racisme
bienveillant incluant mais qui jouent
sur des stéréotypes
alors vous me direz dans une période de
crise globale telle que celle que l'on
vit la fin justifie les moyens
non les moyens conditions de la fin si
vous incluez
sous condition de performances de la
différence vous portez la
complémentarité et non pas l'égalité
vous êtes efficace mais vous n'êtes pas
efficace pour pour aller vers l'égalité
est ce qui explique que d'une manière
pragmatique
au mieux vous justifiez un
positionnement de bons numéros 2
ça permet de comprendre ce qui peut
apparaître un peu irrationnel pourquoi
n'avons jamais nous lui de femmes chefs
d'état vous me direz c'est normal ça
serait pas une bonne paire de la nation
nous n'avons pas non plus de femmes à la
tête de deux chambres parlementaires que
ce soit l'assemblée nationale ou au
sénat
mais je suis mal honnête nous avons une
femme à la tête du journal le plus
valorisé en france le monde une
rédactrice en chef nathalie nougayrède
en 2013
oui mais c'est étrange elle a été nommée
en binôme avec louis dreyfus a en 2016
nous avons eu l'élection d'isabelle
kocher la tête d' angie seule femme
actuellement à la tête d'une entreprise
du cac 40 à elle ou s'il a été nommé en
binôme elle pas avec gérard mestrallet
président non exécutif c'est symbolique
nous dit-on puisqu'il n'a pas de
rémunération oui c'est symbolique aussi
d'autres choses
c'est symbolique d'un modèle papa maman
très hétéronormatif où les femmes ne
peuvent pas des numéros en autonomes
elles sont bien en binôme puisqu'elle
quand elle
elle complète 1 et l'application des
doigts dit sur la parité qui ont été
votées suite à la réforme
constitutionnelle de 99 cents tout à
fait luce 32 ça nous avons été obligés
nous grands pays des droits de l'homme
de mettre en place des lois
contraignantes pour que nous ayons plus
de 5% ou 10% de femmes à l'assemblée
nationale en particulier nous nous
retrouvons donc aujourd'hui avec autant
d'adjoints que d'être joints dans les
communes de plus a mis plus de 1000
habitants
mais si nous regardons un peu plus
précisément il y à 80% des adjoint aux
finances qui sont des hommes et 85 % des
adjointe aux affaires familiales et
sociales qui sont des femmes
nous sommes donc sauf dans une division
horizontale et verticale du travail ou
le papa est en haut et la maman le
complète
ne succombons donc pas à la tentation de
mettre la cerise de la performance sur
le gâteau des inégalités il est en effet
à la fois naïf et cynique de croire que
l'on pour enlever la cerise si elle
gâche le bout du gâteau il sera trop
tard
la cerise or à manger le gâteau nous
sommes en train de changer de modèle
sans l'assumer
même le principe d'égalité est soumis
aux conditions du marché de la
rentabilité prouver que l'inclusion dé
mon frère est rentable que la mixité
performante que la lutte contre les
discriminations et performante c'est
justifié c'est rendre pensable le fait
de prouver que les discriminations sont
rentables et que donc elles deviennent
légitimes résister à cela c'est résister
un double mouvement celui de notre
héritage de la complémentarité et celui
de ce pragmatisme de temps de crise
si nous voulons éviter de délégitimer
l'égalité ayons le courage de prendre la
porte étroite d'une égalité sans
conditions ni de fraternité ni de
rentabilité il ne s'agit pas de refaire
ou de fer fraternité mais de dépasser la
fraternité pour penser une république
pour toutes et tous qui permettent de ne
pas s'enfermer dans cette égalité sous
conditions alors quel type d'alternative
trouvé à ce terme de fraternité on peut
penser à solidarité
on peut penser à camaraderie on peut
penser à des fuites et qui provient d'un
terme grec qui n'est pas connotée de ces
exclusions
l'enjeu est bien de penser une
république vivante une république qui ne
soit pas sacraliser mais qui soit
critique et constructive
ne nous enfermons pas dans une devise
qui souhaitent de vie sous forme de
mantra républicains pour que vive une
république où la liberté et l'égalité
soit la chose de tout et de tous
libérons l'égalité de la fraternité
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]